salut c'est jimmy et je suis content de
vous retrouver pour confiner d'ici et
d'ailleurs sur la première aujourd'hui
on part à la rencontre de quelqu'un que
vous connaissez forcément mais dont on
n'a pas eu de nouvelles depuis un petit
moment déjà
je vous emmène chez patricia tine pour
savoir comment se passe un confinement
[Musique]
salut patricia aux cookies bon ça fait
plaisir de voir comment tu vas mais ça
ça se voit sur ton visage des souriante
et toutes belles elle avait été remise
pour vous c'est vrai même si on est
confiné en ce moment c'est aussi
l'occasion de joutes
je ne sais pas si tu le sais mais oui on
attend ça permet de voir se centrer sur
tout ce qu'on n'a pas le temps de faire
au cours de l'année la cuisine réfléchir
décliner un peu et puis aussi s'occuper
de soi
donc oui je l'être alors pour l'heure
aux événements je savais pas si on
pouvait la bordée mais comme tu en a
parlé c'est très très bien on avait vu
le beau dit quand on arrive le petit
ventre on s'est dit waouh soit patricia
manger un bon haricots rouges ou soit il
ya quelque chose qui se prépare est en
fait finalement c'est la deuxième option
on va pas te demander si c'est un garçon
ou une fille juste ce que tu as choisi
un prénom déjà
non je crois que c'est vraiment très
difficile je ne m'y attendais pas mais
c'est vrai que lorsque tu es pas grand
choix sur un prime qui va déterminer
peut-être le caractère de ton enfant ont
comme elle qui gardera tous âges hic
c'est hyper compliqué je vais m'y
attendais n'ont pas encore de prénom
avoir des racines elle je dis cela en
tout cas tu te concentres sur six ans à
6 ans tombe à cette nouvelle aventure de
deux mamans qui t'attend tu réfléchis
déjà des choses une fois qu'il sera là
ou qu'elle sera là comme l'hôtel et de
penser certains projets de repenser
certains projets et puis d'avoir deux
trois centres d'intérêts donc en effet
je travaille déjà sur plein de projets
qui me tiennent à coeur de poursuivre il
ya plein de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
qui proposent du contenu et et toi aussi
art depuis quelques temps pour ceux qui
ne le savent pas tu as un blog culinaire
qui s'appelle
une idée dans l'assiette et je vais pas
mentir j'ai une passion pour la cuisine
ses crèches et le fait d'avoir du temps
ben ça permet en fait de créer et de
réinventer la cuisine alors la ligne
tout le monde la cuisine locale était
aussi d'adapter selon mes propres
besoins
je suis diabétique récemment vous avez
comme diabétiques donc vouloir voir la
passion jean et et j'ai observé que dans
la communauté d'instagram heures c'est
ce bouquet qui tira avait beaucoup de
personnes qui étaient atteints de cette
pathologie
donc du coup on essaie de se donner les
bons tuyaux d'échangés et puis étrange
waits de manière très bizarre j'ai
découvert le suspense à la rencontre
d'autres personnes qui me suivent et qui
partagent aussi des recettes alors des
recettes sucrées les recettes gourmandes
des recettes salées des recettes très
importante avec des fruits et légumes on
va retrouver dans le jardin ou encore
même faire avec ce prix là dedans dans
le réfrigérateur tic et on se retrouve
avec franchement des déplacements 10 des
recettes qui sont trop trop bien et que
je partage sur mon blog
oui unis dans l'assiette mais également
serait s'aggrave en mode story 4 c'est
vraiment ça qui est bien quand on va sur
sur ton blog
c'est qu'en fait les choses sont
revisités on sent que c'est de la
cuisine saine on a envie de manger parce
qu'on dit ça fait du bien au corps et en
plus c'est souvent mettant en valeur des
produits du pays du thé noir
je crois que des fois tu peux y truquer
dûment jugée au mont avec du curcuma et
c'est des choses qu'on a chez nous chez
un type d'engin
savais même pas ce que c'était et avec
des fous étaient super bien par exemple
le vois je note également où la
guadeloupe c'est l'espèce de 80 de canal
ou de la jamaïque et c'est ben c'est un
fruit qui se font ce super bien très le
sucré et qui est adapté aux diabétiques
mais à toutes les personnes qui
souhaitent construire le web et du coup
pour aujourd'hui tu prépares quoi fait
nous voir vous plaisir
alors du coup franchement on va le
prendre super simple un plat préféré
c'est le blog de poisson noyé le poisson
de prévu avec une mayonnaise maison je
vais vous montrer ça qu'il est juste là
et pour le goûter
comme c'est la période de la pâte à tous
donc alors on prend l'eau d'heure la de
tout ça et ça fait vraiment vraiment
vraiment super envie
on est vraiment content d'avoir de tes
nouvelles de voir que tout va bien pour
toi on a hâte de te retrouver bien
évidemment à l'antenne en télé et on
espère que voilà tu profites bien ton
confinement pour pouponner et en
attendant cet heureux événement en tout
cas merci d'avoir pris le temps de
passer un petit moment avec nous c'était
un petit message à passer à toutes ces
personnes qui te suivent mais aussi être
des personnes qui me suivent les
personnes qui sont cités légalement et
les mouvements les amoureux de la dgi
qui restent chez eux pour la préserver
préservez nabeul et celle des autres je
vous ai de gros bisous et au plaisir de
vous retrouver très nette
on embrasse bien fort ans patricia et
bon appétit surtout c'était un petit
moment passé avec patricia tine c'est
vrai que ça faisait un petit moment
qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis le carnaval
on est ravi de voir que tout va bien
pour elle mais aussi nous avoir suivis
s'était confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs on
reviendra très vite avec une nouvelle
personne à découvrir quelque part
m
[Musique]